the next travel question comes from
Michael in Suleman and it is what are
the most useful travel related apps now
this is what I'm actually always looking
for the next best travel related app so
I I'm just to say full disclosure here
these have been some of my favorite
travel apps for the last five years so
I'm kind of looking for that next big
thing in travel but the first one that I
really like is called trip it and trip
it I had this up here someplace but I
don't think we're sure they've got a
screenshot so trip it actually goes into
your email and you've got to trust trip
it to go into your email and it actually
scans automatically for your travel
related items so it will scan for hotel
reservations it will scan for your car
rentals it will scan for your flight
information and then it automatically
you don't do anything it just puts it
into an itinerary so it's sort of like
having a secretary or a personal
assistant organize your travel
information and then you can pull it up
on your phone and I actually have trip
it here and it brings up all of your
information in an organized itinerary
and what I like about that is you can
actually just forget about it if you
book something seven months ahead of
time it puts it in the background and
then when you're ready for that trip it
will start reminding you about that trip
so TripIt can't say enough good things
about trip it some other good travel
apps I really like Waze that's really
good for traffic in GPS this is a
company that was acquired by Google a
couple of months ago actually about a
year ago now and it does this crowd
sourcing thing with traffic so other
people on the road can tell you where
there's traffic I don't recommend using
it when you're driving obviously you
really shouldn't use it when you're
driving but if you have someone riding
shotgun and they can like sort of man
the road trip this is a perfect tool the
second the third travel app that I
really like because I spent a lot of
time in airports is gate guru this one
tells you what kind of stores or or food
chains are in the gates that you're
going to or the terminals that you're
going to I always have this problem
where I buy something at like McDonald's
and I really didn't want to eat
McDonald's but then I walk another 10
steps and I see oh there were all these
other better things I could have gotten
you